[Music]
hi welcome to episode number 149 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm McConnell and I'm here with my
colleague almost always Melanie Clark
how you doing Melanie I'm mark I'm good
how are you I'm doing all right yes we
are back from strange loop this week at
least for a minute we're together in San
Francisco which is good lovely and this
week we're gonna be sharing another
episode from some of the episodes I
gather and while I was in South Africa a
couple weeks back thank you specifically
for episode 149 we have with us this
week yet people and Jessica who are both
researchers from the ames research group
based in south africa
so looking forward to hearing from them
and talking to them about some of the
research they're doing and other
organizations that are in the area but
before we get into that we will always
do like we do the cool things of the
week and we will end with a question of
the week and so for this week our
question as always coming from mark if
I'm using the cluster autoscaler for
kubernetes or gke how can I prevent it
from removing specific nodes from the
cluster when scaling down I haven't
answered your hands I do you always you
have all the answers not all yeah some
of the answers I have some of the
kubernetes oh you make it sound like you
have it's good it's all good all right
well mark let's talk about cool things
the weekend and we've got one at the top
that's that's of course down your
expertise is it's true
actually I really like this blog post on
the Google cloud blog called a creepy
Nettie's FAQ for the c-suite so
basically for CX o top level or I think
even people who aren't necessarily
technically oriented maybe like not
engineers that kind of stuff but want to
understand what kuben of these is and
what benefit it gives it has a really
nice breakdown of like what is crew
panini's why does kubernetes matter
why does IT like kubernetes so much what
are the main benefits etc how do I get
started that kind of stuff and it has
some technical as well as non-technical
answers as well as different
perspectives that may help you explain
it to people who who sit maybe at a sea
level or like a business level or that
kind of stuff I actually really do we
have any c-suites out there listening to
us I hope so no that's not our target
but but yes we probably have a mixture
of people out there anyway so let me go
ahead and talk about a blog post about
bigquery and surrogate Keys so this is a
how to set up a surrogate key in your
bigquery and this is a nice practical
approach that Marco trinkle in had put
together and he talks about you know how
you can generate it you could do
something
where you're like hashing the row number
there's some alternative approaches he
hasn't run like actually hash of the
record fields and using the result as a
surrogate key so he gives you a step
through on how you can do that and we'll
include that link in the show notes yes
coming up next there's also a great
article from the serverless compute team
talking about adding customer
intelligence to Gmail with serverless on
GCP basically it's a really nice how-to
on how to build your own intelligence
into your own gmail capabilities so if
you've ever wanted to do your own custom
actions based on say a particular email
coming in or set an email or content
inside an email or basically anything
really it keeps you basically pretty
much all the code that you need to do to
do that and set that out for yourself so
if you ever wanted to automate yourself
out of a job or maybe into a job this
might be for you okay now you want to
take it to the next level I actually did
try automating something way back in the
day with my gmail so it's nice to see
that there's some more established tools
that you can use versus trying to write
it from scratch I should try that should
check it out alright well the other
thing we wanted to mention is they are
announcing Google Cloud tasks it's a
task queue you service for App Engine
flex and second generation runtimes so
this is basically a centralized cloud
task API that's fully managed
asynchronous allows you to in essence do
task execution service for any
application running anywhere using a
standard API so it's great for task
queue use and they talk through that a
little bit and help you understand what
that means what that looks like for App
Engine especially considering if you
were using task queues in the past
apparently this is really all the stuff
you would do at squ you will do with
cloud tasks so you can check that out
yeah worth noting like existing App
Engine customers can continue to manage
their tasks why are the App Engine SDK
it's all still going to work that's good
all right I think we wanted to give one
last mention which is sort of related to
something we touched on back when we
talked to Jeff Dean a couple weeks back
yeah yeah so unity and deepmind have
announced a partnership to advance AI
research it'll basically enable deepmind
to develop a lot of virtual environments
and tasks basically for doing a lot of
AR research yeah so the whole virtual
environments we had touched on that with
him a little bit about how that's one of
the values coming out of the AI space is
seeing these virtual environments for
being
experiment and so you should check this
out and see what they're up to
absolutely awesome Melanie why don't we
go have a chat with your friends over in
South Africa sounds good I'm happy to
have with us today
your Babel Fonte and Jessica Paula fella
thank you both for joining thank you for
having us so why don't we start with you
can you tell us about who you are in
your background so I'm yep about Fanta
and I grew up in Ethiopia at this Apapa
and I did my undergraduate studies in
Addis Ababa and then I went to Cape Town
for my degrees masters and then I went
to Italy for my PhD and then did some
postdocs in in Europe and came back now
to Africa with something called the
Robert Bush Foundation they funded this
research here called RIT Eames chair
which is really unusual funding because
it allows you to work anywhere in Africa
and so I'm really enjoying being now
pan-african practically yeah it's just
talking about it so I am doing research
in areas of cosmology which is my main
speciality and also using satellite
images to try to understand in this
Africa going in the right direction and
can we get that not only in the official
statistics but also through some mining
the data which is available free
satellite images so that those are kind
of background I would say that's great
and I know we were talking before you
tell me about some of the travels that
you do for work which is wonderful that
you call yourself in African I think now
I can call it like that and it's really
different when you are really doing it
it's actually much different because you
really start seeing the similarities and
I think I'm now no it's just
philosophically only but practically it
is you know Africa just as one makes
sense and that was probably the reason
why people in the 96 States you know
when they were talking about
pan-africanism they actually probably
felt similar in a way we share a lot
more similarities than our differences
and our differences just within Ethiopia
we have so much difference within
different tribes then probably I have
within other African countries so in a
way you know it's just natural that's
difference it's our beauty and we you
know we should just sell
but at the same time our similarities
are a lot so which is we can capitalize
on that so that's great and then Jessica
can she can you tell us a little bit
about you
okay Thank You Melanie um I was born in
Palo quani here in South Africa and I in
terms of my studies I did my
undergraduate at Wits University and
that was in economics and mathematics I
went on to do my post-grad two masters
level at Fitz as well and my
specialization was in functional
analysis so I'm actually a pure
mathematician oh wow yeah and so during
my master's I realized that I would like
to use the skills that I attained to
work towards PhD that's a little bit
more applied and that's when I explored
data science and then I moved to the
African Institute for mathematical
sciences and I'm doing my PhD in applied
mathematics and the area of my research
is manifold learning and approximation
theory so it does allow me to use those
function analysis and harmonic analysis
skills together with some new skills
like information theory and coding so
it's been really a wonderful experience
that's right and so the Africa Institute
for mathematical science I know both of
you are there
can you tell me a little bit more tell
us a little bit more about what the
institution focuses on in terms of the
research that it does yeah it's like so
with African mathematical science
usually just Ames is founded in 2003 by
a new truck and I think the main idea
was of course
Neil's truck got those ideas but when he
was travelling and he was inspired by
how people think differently in Africa
and he believed that the way of thinking
the mathematical sciences should be the
core and that's where he I think his
vision was like okay let's have
everywhere in Africa not just you know
in South Africa or localized but just
everywhere in Africa let's have like
these examples that could do in any of
the mathematics physics or mathematics
or economics any of them which involves
some mathematical thinking to be you
know leaders and to trying to be the
first kind of an example for others to
follow
so I think it worked I mean
phenomenally and that's why we're still
here and since even like it was in South
Africa only the but then it expanded not
was six other countries in Africa and
it's graduating I didn't that's more
than 1,500 people Wow and from all over
Africa
according to the map that you see
everywhere in Africa is green which
means we have graduates from everywhere
in Africa and that is really great and
then the research aspect came around
2007 it was started in South Africa the
aim South Africa so that one involved
lots of researchers coming some of them
just they are temporally some of them
are research scientists they're just but
maybe affiliated to other universities
for example Stalin Bush and also
University of Cape Town so the kind of
work we do I would say like like there
are financial mathematics researchers
there are bio mathematics and there is a
cosmology which I am part of but which
also now evolves into the machine
learning group and also now the data
science group that jessica is in there
are a lot more coming and going also
which I probably may not cover every of
the mathematical science out she is
covered and what makes aims special is
it actually there are no lectures per se
it's not like it's a very different
intensive one year but a lot more
introducing like you know people from
every everywhere in the world who are
really doing amazing research they come
and teach they're willingly voluntarily
and they basically live with the
students and the three weeks three weeks
module and they interact and basically
just like the students learn not only
the subject but the way of thinking
right so which makes aims I would say
very special and yeah and then Eames
evolved into the whole next Einstein
initiative which is now centered in
Rwanda and which is managing not only
aims but also there is like the next
Einstein a forum which every two years
brings together scientists
businesspeople politicians in one and
this is the first of its kind I mean
there was no such big gathering in
Africa and that's really what you see I
am an extern Stein fellow and it
highlights young people doing certain
research in
and if they are excellent in their
research they bring them together and
then they highlight they give them that
opportunity to expose media and other so
aims and then extends the einstein
initiative is doing really amazing yeah
maybe I don't know if you also like a
student's perspective its perspective I
would say the the one thing that really
stands out about Ames is that it's
research and learning intensive I was at
a university for seven years and the
moment I stepped into Ames I can just
feel the difference it's a collaborative
environment like you said you have
researchers coming from across the world
and it gives you an opportunity to
network and interact with people who are
like-minded who have can maybe share
ideas on the work that you're doing and
also it exposes you to people outside of
the country that are working in your
area and especially when you are
exploring a new area like I am Ames has
given me the opportunity to do research
visits in Berlin and visit a team that's
working that has experts in this field
so that I'm exposed to that and I'm able
to bring back those skills I think
that's just the one thing that really
stands out for me is that it's a
collaborative environment it's an
intensive research intensive environment
and I think that makes it different to
the University Sarah that's wonderful
and you'd mentioned about Berlin what
other additional collaborations are done
between Ames and other groups that you
haven't already touched on like how to
its aims participate with other groups
that are you know within Africa as well
as outside again Ames is not so it gives
degree spur it's actually affiliated to
su Stellenbosch University so most of
the students do projects in Stellenbosch
University University of Capetown reads
other places it's basically it is not
like you know it's an academic Institute
but with wide open door for every
collaboration with different
universities within South Africa
and that is if aim South Africa if its
aims Ghana it would be like with all the
other universities locally as well as
internationally people would come to
have some research visits grants that
you know people come and just stay there
for a month to do some kind of some of
their research and as Jessica was saying
to collaborate that's where you meet
a lot of people not only just the people
from outside Africa but also from inside
Africa they come to teach they come to
research visit and so those Basu those
fascinations to get those nos network so
there's a lot of this networking being
done within Africa as well as also and
it's based on each person's the work
that they're doing how that relates to
other groups as well what additional
groups do you work with in terms of the
research that you're doing so for
example like the cosmology group at Ames
they have collaboration with SK which is
the Square Kilometre Array this is the
biggest radio telescope being built yeah
and we have we have the data science
group there and the data science group
and cosmology group at Ames are
collaborating we work on different
similar projects and also every group
has also their own collaboration that
they bring together for example I have
collaboration in Munich and have
collaboration in Rome and Oslo which I
basically sue that I bring visitors and
I also just I go and visit so it's the
same I think it's just like I was saying
I think there is a lot of this
collaboration sharing yeah this is great
and Jessica you mentioned you were at
Fitz what is Fitz okay so if the full
name is the University of the
Witwatersrand it's in Johannesburg okay
and it's one of our oldest universities
in South Africa and ranked the top in
South Africa yeah yeah I did my
undergrad through out to my Master's
that's good to know
I mean I know most universities do
research do they have a very established
research program as well affiliations
with other groups as well because it
sounds like there's work that's being
done with Amos which mean bits I've
heard of it many times now yes so I
think this is I don't know about in
other fields I think data science I'm
more informed because that's a way it's
you know it directly affects me we have
German research at Ames who's actually
working with some of the supervisors
adds vets and they are trying to also
you know create a community of data
scientists who can collaborate together
so one example of this is there's a
full-year course called the theoretical
foundations of data science that was
started by the former vice-chancellor of
wits and Boubacar bog is that
and what they are doing is taking staff
members who have master's degrees and
introducing them to data science so that
they can explore it for their PhD so it
just initiatives like that are taking
place so I do think that if it's is
taking part in creating programs for
data science and other research areas
that's just one example I'm sure there
meaning our physics sector as well they
have very strong particle physics
research group a string theory they are
very not well known so there are many of
these research groups that are strong
advice yeah and it's very well
established I know another group that
I've heard of talking a little bit about
this as CSIR can you tell us a little
bit about CSIR that you know of yes the
only thing I know is that they are
involved in many sectors of research
yeah so include for example I know them
through the day manage as far as I know
that Center for high-performance
computing which is based in Cape Town
this is gonna be also the one machine
that SK is gonna be using because they
have the experience as well as just the
machines to do it and my master student
have been for example using that just
for his own research so they provide the
high performance computing platform and
so they are involved in many many other
research for example we got our
satellite data from the Sansa which is
in the national space science agency
here and they are also related to this
IR in some way in every branch I go so
it's it's kind of adding one of the main
groups you know I think it incorporates
many research groups it sounds like it's
based in multiple locations because
there is one in Cape Town I know what
about some of the smaller affiliated
groups that you work with what are some
of the examples of those that are you
know they might not be located multiple
locations but they do specific and very
deep research i nev talked a little bit
about some of them yeah i mean there are
many such initiatives for example i came
out from a program called the national
astrophysics and space science NASP
national astrophysics eight space
science program yeah and when i came to
do my
owners and masters who that program it
has trained in the space science and
astrophysics secretary lot I would say
like it has really influenced it the
landscape in Africa in terms of like
graduate now you would find also
graduates from many countries in that
field and that is collaboration again
between almost every University in South
Africa so it's like we we were
collaborating and like with hermanus
Observatory the observatory in Cape Town
satella it's all this collaboration but
every University for example the Western
Cape they have very strong cosmology
group they are doing research they are
one of the main science drivers now in
terms of research I would say for the SK
they have lots of stuff doing in SK and
as I said in which you CT has many
groups cosmology group ethnicity was the
strongest till sometime I don't know now
that's it's like they had a string
theory cosmology which was led by George
Ellis was very in a prominent
cosmologists worked also with other very
prominent scientists in the field so
there are a lot and I mean the Astronomy
Department if you go like they have
researched big research group even those
that I'm aware that I have given a talk
there or I have worked with people it's
you know it's there are a lot of
research groups I want to touch on this
so we're recording this and I I didn't
start out the conversation with this
point but we are recording this at deep
learning in dhaba I've been emphasizing
that a lot when I talk about this on our
podcast we just were actually before we
recorded this at a session where we were
listening to a couple people talk about
democratizing AI in Africa one of the
points that Nando de Freitas made it was
that we need to have AI academic
conferences like in Africa like AI
academic conferences a large one that's
established here and from everything
you're telling me there's you know
significant amount of research now we
haven't touched specifically around the
data science in the AI space but there's
significant amount of research that's
going on but what are your thoughts on
his perspective I definitely agree with
him I have to agree with him especially
as someone who's just moved in to data
science I see the importance of events
like this research can some
be an isolating thing to do and to take
on but when you're brought into space
like this one you get an opportunity to
really put your ideas out there and have
people share their opinions and give you
feedback and I think feedback is really
important especially in a field that is
still developing at the rate that data
science and machine learning is
developing you really want to be in a
space where you're producing work that's
relevant and you only know if your work
is relevant if you interact with other
people you know in that area so this is
really something I wish would take place
that just not the deep learning in dhaba
I wish there would be more conferences
of this nature yeah it really it says
it's an opportunity to put your name out
there as a researcher it's an
opportunity to interact with others it's
an opportunity to get feedback to
collaborate with others and we need to
be at a stage where we can collaborate
across countries in Africa and I think
this is the best place to meet those
people in other countries that are
working on something similar to what
you're working on yeah I think it's I
mean to add on that also I think it's
the most important aspect is that
usually these are signs that people are
taking it serious and people are you
know paying attention governments then
will respond to it and policies with it
so this is just like a sign that also
shows you like okay people have
understood the significance and the
bigger it is it also tells you like
people are active in the field right
they're trying to to work on that and
creating that platform basically I mean
I have seen lots of research came out
from Sudan and other places where there
are no actually staff doing it but the
students are interested right so and
therefore they kind of like this
supervisor but who's also probably not
in the field but they go and do it
the ones I observe it's such a nice
amazing research or the idea is nice for
example one the one that impressed me
was this Sudanese girl she was like
showed me the statistics like okay there
is depression in the Arabic world that
many people die out of suicidal
depression from the mental health
standpoint yeah yeah
in Sudan and so she thought like oh you
know why not can we help them and then
also of course she showed me also some
of the statistics she got from the I
think the UN organization where it's
just young people who are depressed
actually go to social media to say
something about their depression and so
her idea was like oh can we then
discover that early on such that they
can actually you know get help and of
course the the matrix she implied she
collected by hand because she said in
Sudan many of the social medias are not
working so she collected by hand from
Facebook you know she went to group join
the groups all right and then just
collected this data by hand labeled by
hand she got about 3000 from Twitter and
stuff of course there were some flaws I
mean in our derivations but that's it
the point is that she has got everything
but there was no one probably to guide
her through like all the you know the
technical difficulties and coming here
into the deep learning in Taba and just
me being there and at least saying like
okay you know this is an amazing thing
but you have like the sampling issues
these things it's just we'll give her
like that insight right and then she can
form collaborations so all these things
wouldn't have happened if you don't have
such a exactly exposure and venues to
present your work however small it is
but putting your effort outs is that
people can then give you the age to just
go over and you know be what you you can
be and so I think this deep learning
endeavor and similar there is also in
topics but it it's really a great start
and there should be more and you know
for me what really there was a
depressing statistics recently that came
out from McKenzie said it's gonna be
this revolution the AI revolution is
gonna be changing the GDP as more or
less in the same level as the one which
is the first Industrial Revolution which
we know the effect right is like it just
created a massive shift but they're
simulation shows that actually Africa
and other developing countries may not
get the benefit because already the
Lansky's has been so much shifted to
most in the US and in China and other
countries who are already strong so you
really need some kind of intervention to
make you know this prediction
because we want to be participating we
want to benefit from it we want to
change and another like the wave studies
for example the World Economic Forum
they actually put the force industry
revolution to be máxima Africa to be
maximally benefiting from those so there
are these predictions where like Africa
has all the challenges that can be
addressed you know most of them can be
addressed through systematization
resource management and all that and at
the same time here you have like the you
know the economic the GDP thing so if
you match them there is you know like if
these platforms are becoming more and
more I definitely think so simulations
can be wrong what do you think could be
done from a research institution
standpoint to help this GDP issue the
the fact that there is this expectation
that you already ate behind the times I
guess I think what is important is for
us to focus on African problems in terms
of research and not try and produce
research that is not related to solving
African problems whether it be the
drought in Cape Town etc that would keep
our research relevant to the African
climate and also allow the results of
our research to benefit us and maybe
that's when we will see the developments
in AI also benefit our GDP and maybe as
a country or as as African States
another thing I think is research
institutes need to do the very best to
keep their students and not lose them to
universities in North America and the UK
and Europe as the case has been for many
years this causes us to fall behind in
terms of research this also causes us to
not have ownership of African research
for me these are the kind of things that
are just hindering the progress with
respect to research an AI and machine
learning holding on to researchers and
also working on African problems
I think another aspect which I would say
for example another researcher I was
really greatly enjoyed in the poster
session was Jessica's who was working
actually on the foundations of deep
learning you know I believe that it's
just not only you have to and you have
to have we
to build the confidence not just only to
do something but also to follow your
curiosity right so I think what they are
doing for example in this manifold
learning trying to find a certain aspect
such that they can then improve and
understand how the math qualifications
how the black box is working and trying
to them get the you know so competing at
the global at the cutting edge that's
also you need that kind of confidence
and you need to build it right because
without that confidence it's basically
gonna be like we're just gonna be right
happy to be sitting nearby in somebody
right and I think that mentality and
that's why I really like also new trucks
way of thinking sometimes and why this
is a quantum leap African Institute
which is we just started recently and
the whole idea was like yeah like let's
be bold because you know this world I
think they said it again and again it's
only for those really can dream big and
just are not afraid and just going
together so in that it's like in the
quantum like we know okay right now it's
still the game is not decided you know
and data science in AI we have a lot to
contribute so and then we also have to
plan the future to lead for example some
of the expected innovations or
revolutions that may be coming quantum
computing so the quantum leap Africa is
that okay let's gear our mind that we
will be the leaders in that field right
now we have data science let's build
because it requires the computer like
the quantum machine we require
algorithms require like sensors and
stuff
let's build sooo what we have now to
that let's have all the expertise let's
not be worrying about whether it's this
or that it's like let's build our
confidence let's have like that kind of
ambition because it's only the ambition
and I think I can share so many times
that the people in West Africa about
when they play football it is their
ambition that drives them that makes
them you know play in Europe and people
in Kenya and in East Africa in general
when they ran which is just also part of
me know partly irreverence
I just think about winning right it's
like I I just even don't think about
that confidence was built by few people
who broke just
it's kind of sphere where it was
blocking and suddenly someone just got
gold or they were just the best players
and then people were like it was me it
was just you know I can relate my life
there was nothing special and so it's
just you know you build that confidence
and so like all these ambitious projects
as well as I'm also leading the
community of scientists in Africa which
incorporates the next Einstein fellows
and next Einstein ambassadors from all
over Africa and we are trying also
exactly to do like we are doing
something we are close to the research
in the knowledge and the politicians are
very close to the decision they have to
do every day it's a hard job right the
business people have to deal and they
have to survive so that's dialogue we
can't for money we keep I have the time
to think and we have the time to reflect
we are easy to the data we can analyze
and get insight and then we have to
share that one so we have like in this
policy advising so we have objectives
like to try to be like advising a you in
some because these fellows and Masada's
are working on every field from medical
to climate to Kannamma --kx to you know
computer science I mean data sign so
it's everywhere we have all those fields
and we're increasing we're not just like
fellow and ambassador it's all about
let's build the community and like this
community contribute in all forms just
like it's not to be dormant having that
the whole point let us not be passive
and in this transformation all the work
the fundamental work the pure
mathematician has a lot to contribute as
well as you know the the one who's doing
at just basically in the clinical
testing in some remote places so there
is a lot more to do so I think those
would I would say contribute in making
sure if we keep doing them and the right
way I think it will make the this
predictions wrong and I noticed when
I've been talking to people at the
conference that there's a common fear
that I don't know enough I'm afraid to
jump in but yet I'm here because I'm
interested and I'm bringing this up
because I've talked to a lot of people
who are in this space or who want to be
in this space in many locations I've
been very lucky in that regard to be
able to talk to so many people who are
trying to get into AI from all over the
world and there's that that common fear
in common
intimidation it's everywhere and it's
here and I've heard people talking about
this here as well
so you're talking about the confidence I
think that the question becomes like how
to encourage people who don't feel like
they know I think that's also the key to
you know feel like they know enough and
they're afraid how to encourage them and
what do you think can be done to help
make sure that the barriers to entry
don't feel as intimidating okay firstly
I think one of your first questions was
why do people feel intimidated by this
area of study and I think from what I've
seen thus far is that machine learning
or data science is a multidisciplinary
area and I think that's the intimidating
part that mathematics alone is not
enough you know it's a combination of
Statistics mathematics and computer
science and that requires if you come
from any of those angles you're going to
be required to broaden your knowledge on
the other topics so I think that's the
first thing and I don't think it's
something that should be seen as a you
know barrier and because the support is
there especially in universities
especially because this is an upcoming
field so supervisors Institute's are
aware that people who are doing research
in this area require a little bit more
support in that regard I think
conferences such as this one do help
provide you with that confidence like
yeah Bob L was saying I'm working on a
problem and being able to present to my
peers and present to people who are more
experienced in this field also allows me
to gain more knowledge and allows them
to also a nudge me in the right
direction provide me with the resources
that I need so these kind of conferences
are really it's really important to have
these kind of engagements way when you
present someone might be a little bit
more experience in that field and just
talk on something that for them is just
a quick aid is a resource once you've
taken a look at this it will push in the
right direction oh hey here's my email
address let's meet up and we'll take
this further so I think that's that's a
good starting point I mean there are
many other things that can be done but
this for me is
in the year that I've been studying this
has been one of those moments where have
you learned so much in a period of four
days it hasn't even come to an end yet I
think that that really does get the job
done just to add on that I think it's I
think she said most of the things also I
would have liked to say in terms of this
kind of platforms definitely put you in
that one thing like the people who you
know we're doing great out there and you
the differences are like not that big as
you think and so it just gives you the
proof to yourself to check that you are
in the right direction or this is the
things you miss or the things you
thought it's big it's not big the kind
of gives you the laboratory to check for
yourself and usually those I believe are
the only way that you will get confident
right so another aspect that I'm working
on that because that's for me the most
important thing that happened to my life
so I realized directly to it is that
because you know you you could be
planning I mean I was ambitious
you know above aquila for me was like
yeah like what did he do they above
Aquila is one of the runner in Ethiopia
who cut the first Olympic gold meter and
in the 1960s he was the first African to
actually do that and it respired the
generation of runners you know from
Daraa and there were things he did which
I don't know how that relates that fits
but for me no I like the narratives
because it's really helps me he was
running barefoot and he was training any
type a barefoot and he went to Japan in
the Tokyo Marathon then he was given a
shoot to run to and he was like and he
had to decide I mean that's my narration
you know I like to put it and you have
to decide to run on this thing that he
hasn't got used to everyone is doing it
or just do his way the way he knows
right and I think for me the most
spectacular event was he decided to just
run barefoot just his own way and then
you know here on just completely made
history right so so I think one thing I
draw from that experience and the same
can be said I think in the western
Africa for the football probably is it
people to achieve greatness they didn't
just have to pretend you know they had
to do their own way right and they had
to be taking
consequences right so for us I took that
inspiration for me and we have this
project which is I would say a
significant fraction of my three years
in the last three years I spent thinking
about it because that's what's important
it's like what checking every detail in
and how you moved in this space and what
we do is that it's actually it
influenced it whom you knew when you
were a child like did you know a
mathematician I mean and if not when you
become a mathematician you won't be
confident right it's like because if you
like you may not understanding it the
right way if you didn't know a physicist
when you get into physics you're not
sure but it just seems so naturally so
nice is that even just one handshake
when you were like probably four years
old with a physicist could have changed
that thing a lot because then that
propagates in time like we are like when
you talk with your peers you probably
would say like yeah I know a
mathematician you know they do this
thing but then you think and every time
you say those statements you're actually
thinking right so it just doesn't even
need sometimes maybe a lot it just needs
people everywhere in remote areas they
need to see the real people doing that's
role modeling so what what we are doing
we have this project which is really you
know and I say it's the significant part
of my thinking in the last three years
spent on that is that we have a straw
bus it's European so what we do is that
we're taking the bus we get all the
people and we don't distinguish because
abstraction and Composition is like you
know an idea you obstruct it and then
you use those abstracts to compose there
is mathematics that is physics that is
art that is fashion design that is pain
thing that is poem that is everything
like you get you get to some abstract
level you use that abstract label to
create some symphonies right just take
music notes to same funny same so we
take that one so we bring everyone we
don't all those people who believed in
it but we're also doing things like real
fashion designers if it's scientists
scientists who really have that ambition
and to do inventors so we have like art
science and innovation we put together
we put in the pass and we just drive
across the whole country and we just
scare off and we just you know what we
do is mostly not teaching it's not
about teaching it's about belongingness
you belong to me I belong to you we are
in the same you know family so when you
know me and when you see me now in a TV
you will say I know that I know I'm a
team like and that's that confidence we
we take that inspiration and we are
doing it and we are trying to expand it
also in other parts we want it for
example in round I wonder one these to
do it in Senegal I want the Senegalese
to do it because that relation cuts that
barrier it's like you may have a
different opportunity it's like so in
Ethiopia we want to do it with
Ethiopians we're doing in IBM we're
doing in Silicon Valley we're doing in
researching cosmology and fashion
disaster want them to be there and just
check because then the kids don't have
any more reasoning to say like they are
different right there because I love the
fact there are many people here who come
to this conference who are very much
junior very much just entering the space
who are how you know have taken the risk
have have overcome their intimidation
and also I've seen so many people who
welcomed the men and been very inclusive
and that's been really impressive before
we wrap up I just want to touch on a
couple of things any other like things
that you've seen that you were really
excited about by this conference that
she wanted to touch on that you wanted
to mention I think there are as I say I
mentioned some of them I really was even
if Jessica is James and we talked and I
know her supervisor it was very good to
see what they are doing I can so I went
to her poster and I was like I asked her
you know to tell me in detail like
what's going on you know so it was
really impressive to see you know that
confidence of like really working on
just the foundation of deep learning
especially this black box that you know
we still don't understand trying to find
and and their mater is different and
clever and I'm you know I'm not
qualified to say anything but it's
really impressive that people are
thinking and and pushing in the boundary
not only just in application side but
also just in the pure and the pure math
science and another aspect it's just you
know those people that is one example
but I have seen other people doing
really clever but more of a concerned
from their own you know like what they
think is a problem so then they're
trying to use the methods like available
and trying to improve life right so I
think those are that's where the moments
I was very much happy that I am here and
even if I'm not at you know a big
believer of in this big big conference
are like we draw ourselves right and we
just look and we meet networking is the
biggest thing for me in this kind of
things and as I say me talking to that
person the other person talking and just
guiding the here and there and other
person guiding me on the problems they
have and so these things are what I
really value from big conferences know
the content will change you know so I
think yeah those are the kind of moments
that makes me feel like yeah like we
need to do more I think this has to be
not just one in dhaba there should be
more in such a way that because you know
for such a billion population and the
huge size one conference is not justice
so definitely as a Nando's is saying
it's just is really we need to increase
and we have to bring also the global
competitors such that they can see this
talent such that you know there is fair
collaboration that people could do hear
something like amazing that could be
highlighted I mean not only just change
the lives of people in Africa but also
in the lives in and in the world because
we have a lot of different insights and
I think that's what's also neat attract
believes is that if we really have the
chance to really grow it's because we
see problems differently
ya see that's our gift so we know we
can't compete with that thing that's our
all resource oh thank you that's thank
you okay Jessica what about you um yeah
maybe I can just say three things yes
one of the first things is the coding
lab sessions have been very useful I
think for those like you said who are
new in the field it gives you exposure
to the different topics across from
CNN's our names - just deep feed-forward
models it just gives you that exposure
you need so if you're still in the
process of identifying your problem and
developing your problem
secondly for those who are more
established in the industry I think it's
also great for them to just see what
students are getting up to and other
researchers are getting up to I think
it's been a great time for students to
also almost making new relationships and
I know a couple of people who actually
found Co supervisors during the
conference which is great and some who
have identified potential supervisors
yeah so that's just wonderful and then
within the students as well we are
coming up with ideas of how to bring a
small scale endeavors into the rural
areas going back to like I said I was
born in Palo quani
and this is something of great interest
in a part of a foundation called Sally
Sadie and we do this at a low scale so
something like this motivates us and
gives us inspiration of how to change
the current sort of method that we are
using when we go back into community in
one week this conference is able to
achieve so much so this is a time for us
to also be inspired as students who want
to give back to the community on what is
the best way to do so to learn from the
best how to run a lab session because in
the rural areas they aren't a lot of
laboratories in fact the rural areas
that I've been to students are not
exposed to computers so it teaches how
to efficiently give back to the
community if this conference can do this
in one week it's inspiring us to go back
into the community it can take one week
to also change students lives and give
them that representation that he was
talking about that's great
all right last question for you both in
a couple words can you tell me if
there's any key resources that you
recommend based on you know what your
experience has been and anything else
that I might not have coverage that you
wanted to make sure you touched on
before we wrap up just can I start with
you okay so um one thing that's been
very useful for me as Coursera if you
are someone who's moving from pure
mathematics or pure statistical
background I think Oh Sarah is a great
place to start because you really get to
learn in your private space and there
are no limitations to your learning I
went through a number of courses some 11
weeks you can really cut down that time
if you're really focused and they will
give you explore
like the machine learning course just
gives you exposure to an array of
different algorithms so if you're new to
the field casera go onto the website
explore the different options that are
available and it will just give you far
more exposure then maybe a semester
course would so definitely that and yeah
and obviously just always go through
papers in the fields that most interests
you that's a good starting point that's
always a good starting point to thank
you yeah I think mmm I would say I think
those are great resources and there are
many online courses that are very very
very good like that people don't have
excuse me an issue could be language and
that's I think that's what's this the
Google AI in Ghana and others are trying
to an IBM I know it's they're also
working so they're trying to fill that
gap between you know people who don't
understand
well another I think just if I mention
one other resources like the karpati
page which is very good in sometimes
bringing some complicated concepts in a
very easy way so I think those are I
mean I think out put those links there
and yeah those are great ones and and
last words of advice being take risks
yes I think we need to go in the
direction it hasn't been tried before I
just yeah because otherwise we know the
ones did work so try new directions try
new directions thank you
both of you very much for joining me
today I really appreciate it thank you
so much thank you again you people and
Jessica for coming on to the podcast and
sharing your insights around a our
research that you're doing in the area
and you know other groups and what's
going on so we appreciate you coming on
the podcast yeah thank you very much
mark
yes if I'm using the cluster autoscaler
for kubernetes or GK how can I prevent
it from removing specific nodes from the
cluster when scaling down so cluster
autoscaler for communities is something
I've been digging into lately it's
actually a really cool technology in
that what it does is that as you create
more and more pods through essentially
any mechanism deployments or other such
things if it finds it there isn't enough
room for those pods to exist it will add
nodes up into a special
limit that you add so it'll be like oh
you've now got a thousand so let's make
sure there's room for that and we'll add
nodes in timely manner
vice versa if you were like oh I only
need now 100 now where I had a thousand
it will sort of scale it back down again
all very cool but there are some
scenarios where you might want to be
like don't remove that nodes like right
now it's fairly arbitrary in terms of
what it removes it just make sure that
there's still room for things you need
and things like that it will kill like
empty ones but there is actually some
control that the cluster order scalar
gives you as well if there's particular
nodes maybe you're running a daemon set
on or you have specific hardware on a
particular thing you want to make sure
it doesn't get brought down and there's
a couple of interesting ways you can do
this and I think this is actually really
cool so at the node level there is a
annotation you can add basically a scale
down disabled is true so if you add that
to a particular node it's just gonna go
nope I'm not gonna touch that one it's
fine I don't care but the other thing
worth noting is sometimes you might not
know what node you want to prevent being
able to get rid of what you actually may
also want to be able to do is say hey if
there's this particular pod running on a
particular node don't kill that node and
so you can actually do that too I didn't
realize this up until recently and I
thought this was really cool if you add
the annotation safe to evict false on
the pod whatever node that is on the
cluster autoscaler will not remove that
which is also cool too there's a bunch
of other restrictions as well - will
link to a FAQ in the show notes it all
talks things about stuff about projects
reps and budgets and a few other things
but I thought it was also just really
nice that the cluster order scalar gave
you that kind of control both of the
node level and at a pod level to be able
to control what it does when it scales
down because usually scaling down that's
the trickier problem nice yeah
thanks for that insight okay mark where
you gonna be next week where am I gonna
be next week we're gonna be this month
this month I may be you know delay I
still need to make a decision on that
I'll see what's happening there in
October but I know you said this month
but I'm really excited because I'm going
to my first cube cone in December and I
got accepted as a speaker so I'm really
excited to see a whole bunch of people
at coop con good that's awesome what do
you have - I am going to be speaking
this week at Munk tober fest over in
Maine and then I will be a camless which
is a security data conference that's in
Washington DC the last week awesome
that's the plan fantastic well Melanie
thank you so much for joining me for yet
another podcast
thank you Mark thank you all for
listening and
see you all next week
[Music]